You're glued to your TV,
watching your favorite show,
and there's a heart-pounding moment
where a beloved character needs CPR.
Oh, man!
What's gonna happen?
Oh, they're fine?
That's because it's TV, and not real life.
In reality, CPR is a way to keep a victim
of cardiac arrest alive before
additional treatment arrives.
However, survival rates are much lower
than what's shown on TV.
For instance, one 2018 paper included
18,000 hospitalized cardiac
arrest cases who received CPR.
Overall, only 28.5% of the adults survived
to eventually leave the hospital.
Now let's compare that
to TV medical dramas.
A team of researchers sat down and watched
91 episodes of Grey's Anatomy and House.
They discovered that about 70% of people
who received CPR survived on the TV shows.
That's over double the survival rate
compared to actual reality.
And of course, Hollywood is
allowed to bend the truth
for the sake of suspense,
but in this case,
this misinformation can be misleading.
Many doctors actually opt
out of CPR for themselves.
There are even cases of
doctors tattooing their chests
to make sure that they don't receive CPR.
It may sound paranoid, but doctors know
even if you beat the odds and survive,
your quality of life
may never be the same.
That's because of how CPR actually works.
CPR stands for
cardiopulmonary resuscitation.
When the heart stops, breathing
air into the person's lungs
and pressing down on their chest
keeps oxygen flowing to the brain,
and it may restart their heart.
But what they usually
don't show on TV dramas
is that CPR can fracture your breastbone,
crack ribs, and bruise your lungs.
These types of injuries are common
because your heart is inside your ribcage
and surrounded by other organs.
So in order to make an impact on it,
you have to compress the chest
by about five centimeters,
and of course, our ribs aren't designed
to withstand that kind of force.
And even worse, brain cells start dying
six minutes after the heart stops.
So people who don't receive CPR right away
are at risk of permanent brain damage.
For example, one study in
China found that about a third
of survivors had some
level of brain damage.
Now, just because TV shows
get most of this wrong
isn't the problem, it's
the fact that we believe
a lot more of what we
see on TV than we should.
When 269 people were asked
where they got information
about CPR, almost half said
they used TV shows as a source.
One survey found that nearly
a quarter of older people
believed that 90% of CPR cases survived,
which may lead them to
opt for CPR themselves,
and that's really problematic
for people over 65
who have a lower survival
rate than younger patients.
So when it comes to medical advice,
and I can't believe I have to say this,
don't depend on the doctors on TV.
Ask a real doctor.